it is very difficult I mean how do you
teach about other face but here's the
thing I think it would be quite a
breakthrough to just to accept that you
can at least acknowledge other faiths in
the teaching about your maybe you're a
country with one faith that is very
predominant but even in the course of
teaching about culture or religion if
you if you involve notions of other
faiths and at least describe them i
think that is both helpful important so
my my youngest child a she goes to a
Catholic school you know because we have
faith schools in the UK but in the
course of his religious instruction they
will teach them about other face but
here is what is really important
actually less important than the order
in which you teach them and though I can
see that's got a lot of sensitivities is
what do you teach them about what that
other faith means because that's really
tough and you know I have come across in
in situations in different parts of the
Western world the most frightening stuff
taught about what the religion of Islam
is really about for example and
instantly in the Arab world really bad
stuff about what Judaism is about so and
you know one of the things that I work
on with the Palestinians is to make sure
that when you've got an education
program in their schools is actually
educating you about peaceful coexistence
between religions because I said so much
she's telling you you're going to make
peace with it Israelis next door if what
you're learning in school is a bunch of
bad people so you know it's not going to
help so these things are really really
important I think and sometimes you know
I come across pretty shocking you know
statements about Islam and what it means
and and you know but partly again here
is where the media can play a very
difficult role I mean you will remember
the guy mr. mr. hook in the UK remember
that guy who spent three years Prime
Minister chronic expelled from the
country but this guy was like something
our central casting right you know I
mean he it'll look crazy and had one
missing with a hooking things and would
come out make these wild statements
supposedly on behalf of the Muslim
community which were actually not
supported by very many people and then
was some community at all but people
like that were then taken as sort of
representatives in when people are
learning about Islam and it just
incredibly damaging and dangerous so I
think the single most important thing is
actually what you do teach about the
other religion